where the real power resides where I  come from there lots of people in fact  more than a billion it is the world's  largest democracy maybe that's one  reason why I'm passionate about people  and the aspirations and their concerns  my first television report was right  here in Berlin after the fall of the  Berlin Wall and I remember thinking at  that time if the Berlin Wall came for  anything can happen if people come  together and unite for a cause when I do  the news are often confronted difficult  situations war conflict pain disaster I  see it as part of my job to confront  world leaders on policies and  development to put the spotlight on  issues that matter most hunger food  security oppression marginalization a  lot has been achieved but so much more  needs to be done and I think people have  to be at the heart of solutions my name  is Omri fatima and i work at DW  [Music]